Jackson Mississippi Travis is on the
line hey Travis how are you good how you
doing Dave better than I deserve sir how
can I help
well my wife knives the major surgery in
2016
open-heart surgery for me and she's a
cancer survivor with surgeries and so
we've been paying off medical debt Wow
and doing a lot of odd jobs we both
teach school and so we're just we went
through the emergency fund and we're
building it back up but trying to stay
focused between the side jobs and main
job hmm so how much old debt that you
have now total debt with the house we
have a hundred ninety seven thousand
like now I count okay not count my house
five thousand left on medical 24 own
cars and 22,000 in college yeah okay
what's your household income it is a
about sixty three to seven thousand I'm
sorry ninety three thousand look at the
numbers oh okay all right okay well
here's the thing if we just said two got
to two folks that are teachers in
Jackson Mississippi just call me they
make ninety three thousand a year and
they got five thousand twenty two
thousand twenty four thousand and debt
which sounds like a lot like about fifty
three thousand bucks how fast could you
pay off fifty three thousand bucks
making ninety three thousand bucks
pretty quick you know you do it within
two years probably you wouldn't think
much about it but you just added
something to the equation called cancer
and heart surgery yes and and the truth
of that matter is twofold one is
physically you don't feel super
energetic like your old self yet so to
speak you know and on top of that you
guys emotionally have been gut-punched
you've been looking at your wife going
through cancer treatments she's been
looking at her husband going through
heart surgery and that has no small
effect on how how our emotional gas tank
stays full you know and
if you guys hadn't slowed down and lost
focus we would say you weren't human you
were robots cuz humans when they hurt
this much it slows us down right yeah
let's give you permission to be a little
bit unfocused for a little while or slow
down for a little while maybe you're not
on your a-game well no duh cancer and
heart surgery and a short period of time
of course we're not on our a-game we're
recovering is what we're doing right
yeah so I just tell you you know if you
didn't have all that other stuff going
on you'd be dead free in two years it
may take you in this situation three
years but you can do it but you just you
know Madonna have quite the focus you
don't quite the energy well yeah I
wouldn't either if I'd been through
worse you've been through is that okay
okay yeah yeah thank you for taking the
call and hearing and giving some
encouragement advice you can do it man I
know you can do it even in spite of
these things we're not going to give up
because of cancer in heart surgery but
you know you know are we walking with a
limp yeah sure sure we're gonna run be
running full-speed here right now that's
okay okay do what you can do and that's
enough for today
and then tomorrow do a little more and
then the next day do a little more do
what you can do and that's enough for
today
hey man thanks for calling in y'all get
better soon